record if you look at these two
tweets we've claimed that we've beaten
Pokemon Red with online RL
that is the
claim so uh where is it this
[Music]
thing where was the darn emad
tweet typical emad misrepresenting
[ __ ] uh oh my gosh how much does he
tweet okay there we
go we did not claim to solve Pokemon as
a
benchmark this is not what we claimed
so for Tim
here this criticism is a criticism of a
claim that we do not
go now we will get on to real work
welcome YouTube
folks what we're going to be doing at
the moment is trying to get this kernel
working this Cuda kernel working for
this Advantage function that is the
center piece of the new RL algorithm
that I'm
doing
and and I have to figure out what's
wrong with
this apparently I'm just passing it the
wrong signature
so
tensor
sir wait
eight eight tensors 1 2 3 4 four five
six seven eight eight tens
right no why why do we have more than
that and why do we have more than
that Advantage kernel one two three four
five six seven
int why does it
say ar9 is an
INT 2
in what oh there's an AR zero okay we're
good so it's zero index so one two three
four five six eight nine yep there are
nine of
these okay and then we
do one 2 three four five six seven eight
nine then two
in in
in flat
the heck is wrong with this is this not
how you call this with grid and block
corrected okay so then this is this gets
passed
from I don't know how this gets computed
but whatever let's see if this does
it
okay that's something
now
there actually why don't we just
we'll see how the uh the curves
differ I'll be pretty impressed if this
zero shots it but I won't be baffled
because honestly Cuda for this is pretty
easy
like the more um oh yeah that's looking
decent um but seriously like the more I
learn on like the lowle dev side when
people are saying oh it writes Cuda
kernels it's so hard no no it's
not
silly simply just not that hard
I add some runs I was looking at here
there we
go that's a Cuda kernel for
you that is a Cuda kernel for you
and that match is
perfect
Bo up to nearly a million steps per
second on this
programming I think debugging these is a
pain though right yeah debugging Cuda
sucks so I still wouldn't want to write
like you write kernels in it right you
don't write whole chunks of stuff in
it big Cuda programs would be a pain
debugging sucks well this fun
that's totally fine now we have
this um do we want to fall
back we probably want a fall back right
let's go do the rest of the
optimizations
here probably ship a Cuda version of
generalized Advantage estimation if we
wanted to that' be easy
enough so what we have
15 15% overhead right now
right and we have a whole bunch of
redundant stuff
like
this
this and where's reward
okay all we have to do
is reward block will be
this Mas
block
this buff is already
done advantages is already done
great I think we just have a bunch of
redundant stuff we can get rid of right
this oops kill
Neptune you don't need Neptune on every
NP there we go what CPUs you getting
with the new boxes when we get them 9950
X's
12% Customs at
zero hang on how is custom at
zero the m is at
now oh yeah this is fast as
hell yeah we are good we are absolutely
good
here we're going to ship Cuda
Colonels I don't know I might get Cuda
fever and write even more Cuda we'll
see might just do some Cuda op them make
everything even
faster cuz this just made uh this just
solved the problem with this
what's the
uh what is the difference at the moment
in
performance if I do this
we got 1.2 Milli
right 1.1 1 point2 something like
that and if I do
this 20% not quite 20% like 15% I guess
per dip Maybe
see so we still have five extra perc in
Miss learns 29 four is
[Music]
11 copy is 11 or 12 embis 15
1 I wonder if the model is just very
slightly heavier
now it could be
really shouldn't be
though well I mean we'll definitely get
uh very very close if we can just take
this MK
down let me make sure I actually know
where it is
first I want be absolutely sure that
it's right
here oh yeah we got 8% right
here
9% that's pretty much all the over
yeah there's your 5% Gap right
there okay
is this the operation right here hang on
7% in
this is
[Music]
5% what about
this it's
like yeah okay so can I just
Voss is this the same
thing
no times mass
block that's some you have to do this
one I
think how's
this
six7 7% 8%
I also don't even have clipping on here
yet so I guess I probably want to
compile this right
we'll see if it's actually faster let me
see
Frack you always know the advantage
right
go
you don't need any of these things in
the signature
right you don't need advantage in here
either stupid auto complete
is this all you
need yeah it
isg
okay had what
12% in
no it's not faster you forgot the
decorator
help it just makes it take a little
longer to start up
well actually I see something here we
can
do that we're going to actually remove
this
old and remove
this actually we can keep it for now in
case we decide we want
it I think I see something
that saves a little
bit does
uh we have to do
this this little bit here
we're fighting over like such a little
bit no
4%
okay P30 Horizon
n LL
dimension that's not any
better better at
all I mean I don't know why I would
expect it to be to be
fair kind of just screwing around trying
stuff at this
point hold on
maybe maybe I mask
first for
faster that's slower
right much
slower much much
slower it's annoying
how that
the issue
is hang
on come out of the
from I know what the maskk comes from
that's
fine the mask comes from the computed
Advantage
right speaking of which I hope we still
compute that
I think we would have to
yeah these three indices are going to
mess it
up so I guess it's better better to
just do it the previous way
I mean the per overhead is like almost
negligible
here we're at 1.2 mil
here yeah I think we're pretty darn
close
to
negligible 7%
yeah it's within it's within like 5
10% I think we can torture you know I
can torture myself over
this for as long as I want but for now
this is pretty
solid think yeah fixing the end of
overhead and such will be higher
priority but getting this algorithm
running over a million is really nice oh
we do have to we do have to see how the
overhead scales
unfortunately that is going to be an
issue
p3o Horizon
bad going see if there's um overhead up
here or something
4% yeah that's way better than
before okay I'm like I'm way happier
with this at
least
so actually I think the first thing I
want to do is just run
up we have uh
not this
one where is this
thing I thought we had
a we had a nice window somewhere
oh here it is this is it right here I'm
looking at
it you
[Music]
know I have some hope for
this I definitely have some hope for
this I think it's going to take some re
architecting on Saturday or whatever
but I think we'll be able to get the
this parameter to behave the way we
expect it to
381 all right so definitely don't do
this for
now but this still
works this works at over a
m so we should be able to get something
out of
later going to do this
Dill
annoying okay let's merge that real
quick
improvement with
um rock or whatever kind of but the
thing is like
it's not that impressive look it's like
oh Cuda is big and scary right it's just
C so I already had scyon code that looks
I mean this is what the Cuda kernel
looks like
okay and this is
the this is what the scyon looks like
it's almost identical
yeah food is not that hard it's
literally just C that runs on your
GPU anyways P30 is now basically the
same speed as po at least for short
Horizons we'll be able to do some
optimization more on top of that but uh
this should be good now the only thing
that's annoying is we do have to update
the the
containers to
be uh
development instead of Base which is
obnoxious but no big
deal I want to get some stuff running on
this let me think how I'm going to do
that and we're going to just have to
ship the new
container or you like use
it and it's been ridiculously
busy
lately I've like barely had time to
shower or eat properly
this I think that uh we will probably
whoops
are I have anything going
here guess
not nothing in
there good
rebuild unbx
zero so we can run
this you have to build this thing
manually don't you
oops we'll take a few minutes to rebuild
these here so I can play with
does yeah though that you definitely
like the training Loop
the python overhead and the kernel
launch overhead and stuff is just
disgusting there's um
substantial performance to be gained by
like fusing stuff
together I don't know maybe we'll do
some Kernels at some point who knows
maybe we'll do some
Kels Pokemon Pokemon announcement is
doing
well well
enough
ah well the idea we will just get this
running and then I'm going to Port some
code for uh some collabs Port some code
over to some stuff real
quick and this will be good we'll have
gotten P30 relatively perf optimized
today we have our first Cuda kernel and
puffer I'm sure we'll have distribution
hell with those but we'll figure it out
um have to look at what P torch
does we'll see maybe we do scyon fall
backs for puffer stuff we'll say but I
think probably we'll do c
fallbacks I don't know
how annoying is it to get Cuda to run on
the
web it just wouldn't work if
um you're on a laptop that doesn't have
that right
Cuda in videoid
specific so I guess it's web GPU not
Cuda it's a pain in the
ass I think we'll leave our like little
poer Dems the way they are we'll focus
on the RL stuff that
matters get this new algorithm tested
nicely
because I'm actually wondering if it's
going to get more sample efficient just
because we made it
faster seems kind of
possible like with the way that this is
set
up that'll at least give us a much
closer
comparison to uh to PO
be there's still some things on the
algorithm to be fair that I'm not happy
with
so and uh I think regardless the things
that I do will also make Po better so
we'll do that over the weekend most
likely that seems like a good use of a
I definitely need to clean up the repo
and prune some stuff
get the Clone time fast
right unknown or invalid runtime name is
Nvidia what in the
container we have K to 124 support
here 550 drivers right
point4 no such container
Dash
oh it is getting picked up by a
torch 1.2
Milli
[Music]
use3 do
this 1.1
mil all
right we happy with
that auto auto
auto that's
[Music]
good happy with all
okay I just need my
token we will have the sweep
see 1.2
mil for this new
run it's kind of
nutty oh yeah you're getting the
overhead twice cuz it's two update EPO
yeah this is
nice it's very
happy this is fast million step per
second
training at
least new
algorithm new
sweeps I'm
good I still have to do some porting
work unfortunately
I get to
sleep it should be pretty quick if I can
just get it set
up uh
fast where is
it not this
I think we need to go
to where is it this
one yeah right
meant they don't have a freaking file
for
this I guess they have requirements
text with everything freaking pinned
it's literally not even available
anymore from
up are you going to create a Cuda en if
so
no I did um it's not an environment I
just shipped it actually in
Dev I need to go through it because it's
just a Croc Port of um my scyon code
it's like very basic but it's it's good
um let me find
it so this is just a Cuda implementation
of uh a new Advantage function that is
the key piece of a new algorithm I'm
developing
and it was too slow when I had it in
scon so I just put it on the GPU and now
the algorithm is pretty much as close as
it can be to PO
speed and uh we're going to get to run
some experiments on this this is already
running live and now all I'm doing is
I'm porting over some of our perk
enhancements from this to other
stuff uh as for the M we're building
like now that I'm thinking about it
technically we could use a little bit of
Cuda for stuff if we had to but the
launch time for Colonels is pretty rough
so I think we're going to probably push
CPU as uh as long as that continues to
make
sense we can go to Cuda if we need to
but I don't think it'll be needed really
Pokemon release has
been reasonably well
received nice
nice hey
welcome I think this isn't terrible for
uh for day one I mean it didn't like
massively massively blow up but um I
mean we'll continue to get throughout
the week as we post more visuals
there oh yeah it's still there oh yeah
93 on
here that's pretty good
good I'm like half yeah that's the other
half but
still a red it's
rough I just Shi a Cuda kernel to
faster we now have the sweeps on the new
algorithm running very fast fast as
well
oh is this to get around overhead
problems uh yeah the C implementation of
uh this particular Advantage function
was not fast enough why Cuda over TR I
don't know man why rice over pasta you
know uh pasta tomorrow maybe
we'll see how well this does it's
already got a near solve in 100 seconds
so that's that's
something I'm pretty sure this is using
the algorithm right and I guess we'll
find out
PR yeah it be
nice I looked at it it seems reasonable
I just like pushing stuff to 20 just
causes me problems if it's not like a
direct fix to something it usually just
causes me problems that I have to like
then go and be like Ah that's somebody
important complaining that I really need
to not have complaining about stuff
being broken you know
Cuda I mean we could yeah if it's
substantial enough overhead then yeah I
would make
sense the really obnoxious thing is that
you have to provide a
um you have to write it twice right
because it doesn't run Cuda if you run
it on CPU so you need to have a fall
back and they have to
well I'll be quicker
now I'm just getting
oh yeah this is the open AI
thing is it
do well torch compiled doesn't do jack
[ __ ] so
I mean literally as far as I've seen we
get very very little out of compile on
everything I've tried it
like why is why do I think this this
doesn't look like something I'm going to
like
the why why do I think that this is not
something I'm going to like what what is
it that like is saying this let me see
c yeah that's probably what it
is this looks kind of ass not going to
lie
I mean I literally I was like I don't
know Brock write me some Cuda and then I
look at the code and like oh that's dumb
like that's so
easy CPU G
DP
Nvidia
eh why couldn't they have done that just
like why couldn't they have just made my
Cuda code work on the CPU
instead I mean it's actually like the
funny thing about it is like I've been
really enjoying getting closer to the
hardware because just everything is easy
like seriously like I've been writing C
and
like I've been writing enough C that I
like I look at Cuda and it's just oh
this is just C it's just really easy
C I mean I'm sure debugging sucks but
that's like a tooling problem right
I mean we can look at the
kernel it's really
basic like here's the
kernel I add all these buffers in so it
wouldn't have to do any allocations as
well I haven't either but then today I
had one right I need to write a loop the
loop has conditional logic in
it
and it's just
it and it's just C it's like oh I have an operation that
C it's like oh I have an operation that
has to be applied every row of a tensor
equally but it needs to Loop over the
elements in the row dynamically okay
Cuda
done this is literally right here this
is the only like Cuda thing in
here you don't have to think in terms of
anything literally look this is the only
Cuda right here it's just getting your
index from the thread and block or
whatever this the rest of this this is C
I'm pretty sure you can just paste this
and it compiles to
C so like
literally I could just paste this into
another
function and then I could pie bind it
and you'd have a c fallback version
right because that's a c fallback right
there and it would just work and you
just write a for Loop and then the GPU
on the GPU Cuda does the for Loop for
you
that's literally
it that's like brain dead brain dead
fast well just writing any kernel at all
is immediately like way way way faster
than uh
even my C implementation
right diminishing returns looks like
like this substantial block block of
code is no longer causing any
overhead right like this substantial
block of code no longer shows up on the
dashboard when I profile it
I clone the wrong freaking
thing I
did you can go ahead and look at
it but uh I mean for now we're maybe 10%
off of we're like 10% off of uh the perf
of Po and it looks like most of the
difference is just coming from the
like
slightly uh it's like a mask loss
function and the masking is a little bit
expensive it's also a different loss
function in general it's a galxy NL
now we start
pasting we start pasting [ __ ]
in from the current
branch and then these collaborators will
have the fast stuff
paparel see
Y and now I'm goody I don't blame
we should probably just copy in this
whole thing
right I'll just give him the sort Keys
one for
this they're so annoying because it's
like decent chunks of this have
changed
okay and the only other thing I got to
do
[Music]
in C
puffer oh I got to see where it is in
here
dude what the heck is this thing come
on I hate Hydra
it why my leg is just like falling
asleep completely to the point that hold
on as stand up a second
where did they get the freaking config
from they going to drive me
I hate
Hydra I do not like Hydra Sam I Am I do
not like eggs with
ham [ __ ]
hell get how do you even find anything
in
here puffer
yaml they don't have an N batch
size they don't have numb M oh this is
this thing that God damn it I do the
things I do and puffer for a reason when
you change them stuff breaks it's not my
fault damn it if you're going to change
stuff and you break it and you make it
impossible for me to fix it it's not my
damn fault all
right where we make the vum for this
thing a trainer make the vum
here trying to see where
um where they call this from
tools fr
all right that's
done very very nice
this is 900 P p.m. and that's been good
progress I'd say how are we doing
here let me check one thing and then
I'll show some experiments before
back
whoops gu this doesn't matter private
oh now we will look
at make sure our experiments are going
well before we uh all the day this is
what we had
before and
I assume that I actually have the right
flags on this
solved so we'll see how well this does
but this is looking like it's very
likely going to be on par with the
original or
better we will
good 100 seconds for
838 now I just want to make sure real
quick that we are actually running the
thing that we think we're
running that would be a real
shame so let me make sure I
actually train. use P30 true all right
we're using
yeah it's kind of crazy
honestly how close this is to being on
par with po I guess we did just make Po
a little bit faster as well so we
technically will have to rerun that but
uh
before yeah it was like 180 seconds now
we're already down to 100
see I think it was this one was the the
best one with
popl yeah here we go so our
best no not this one I
guess this one
seconds this
one I'm trying to find our best
We There It Is So 80 90 seconds for a
solve call it yeah 85 seconds we'll call
it for a solve was our best
previous with Po and then this training
at uh about 12200 steps per second for
the fastest
ones so it's still going to get a little
faster than
this but the new
ones with the new
algorithm the best runs are still much
slower
interestingly oh that's weird the best
runs are way slower but are still
solvent in uh not that much wall
clock well we will keep going on this uh
eventually this is just going to get to
the point where it's ridiculous and
we're like insta solving this and we're
going to have to throw it on all the
other environments but uh yeah I think
I'm pretty happy with the way this is
going for now so I'm going to get some
rest it's
been heck of a few days here it's been
busy uh I'm looking forward to just
getting more solid Dev
in more solid depth but for people
watching if you're interested in all
this stuff you know we released this
awesome Pokemon RL stuff today you can
check this out here we've been shipping
in Dev tons of perf updates we've got
new M's that are getting merged in got
new algorithms for RL and development if
you want to check all that out at
puffer all the links are here you want
to go ahead and start the repo really
really helps us out and other than that
you can join the Discord to get involved
and you can follow me on X for more RL
content got a Blog here got some more
blog content on the X you can't find
anywhere else that's about it I will be
back probably just tomorrow morning
working on
uh more stuff on the new algorithm more
experiments in the light so